is everything that we know about the
doctor who 60th anniversary special next
year
welcome to scitrak your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
david tennant and catherine tay are back
along with bernard cribbins carl collins
and jacqueline king playing wilf shawn
temple and sylvia noble yasmin finney is
also joining the cast and will be
playing a character known as rose temple
noble which will be donna and sean's
daughter every tenant will most likely
be the 14th incarnation of the doctor
but will not be the 14th doctor because
the tardis that's being used on the set
is actually jody's tardis we also know
this because the episodes that are being
filmed are pegged to be three specials
happening in 2023. shooter gatherer is
not going to be taking on the
manslaughter doctor until 2024. we had
some set leaks and we saw lots of really
interesting information such as a new
sonic screwdriver we have some mock-ups
of it and it looks absolutely fantastic
and we also know about two potential
villains in the 60th special the first
one being beep the meat which is a
character from the doctor who
comic book series like from years ago
and we also have the celestial toy maker
played by neil patrick harris now it
hasn't been confirmed that he's playing
the celestial toy maker but it's it's
heavily implied as seen by some of these
images here now there was also a reddit
leak that confirmed pretty much
everything that i've just spoken about
and in that reddit leak it also
mentioned a classic companion will be
returning now my theory on that is that
susan the doctor's granddaughter back
from the very first episode of doctor
who in 1963 and the
the remaining season she will be
returning now an interesting fact about
susan was she wasn't a time lord she was
just a gala friend so her returning and
being a lot older is easily explainable
because she was left on earth she
married a human and she would have aged
as a normal human so her being older
easily explainable and also caroline
ford the person who played susan is in
her 80s now so for me it's the perfect
opportunity to bring her back for one
last adventure and finally during the
filming in camden we saw what looked to
be someone filming something on the set
didn't look like he was part of the show
it looked like he was filming something
different
a little bit of digging found out this
person to be stefan powell or stephen
powell however you say it who basically
turns out to be a presenter and a
journalist this was later then rumored
by another leak on reddit that doctor
who confidential the documentary series
that complimented the show back in the
revival in 2005 will be returning under
the name of doctor who unleashed
presented by stefan powell i'm sure
there'll be more leaks and more news
coming out in the future and when there
is i'll be making more videos about it
but that's everything we know so far
about the doctor who 60th anniversary
special you are new to the channel make
sure you hit like and subscribe and
consider becoming a fully fledged
sidetrack member hit the join button
down below thank you so much for
watching everybody stay safe and i will
see you in another video
[Music]
you